today we're going to talk about the
number one top food
to
greatly boost your coenzyme
q10 now what is coenzyme q10 well it's a
coenzyme which is a little different
than an enzyme so it's a helper enzyme
well what does it help with well it
helps to make
uh
your energy currency in your body called
atp and this occurs in the energy
factory called the mitochondria so
coenzyme q10 is intimately involved in
making atp or energy it's involved in
maintaining that atp or energy
and it's also involved in reducing the
byproduct
that occurs when you make that energy
which is like oxidative stress free
radical damage so it's a very powerful
antioxidant so it'll be equivalent to a
specialized gasoline in your car
that would not give you any exhaust
exhaust being the oxidation the free
radical damage so the reason why we need
so much coenzyme q10 in our heart is
because that is the part of the body
that generates
the most energy out of any part i mean
it has to generate a lot of energy and
it's constantly beating 24 7
it never really relaxes and so you need
this specialized coenzyme to maintain
that energy and because it produces all
the energy it comes with a lot of
exhaust so we also need to clean that up
as well so that's why coenzyme q10 is so
important and so a lot of people take it
for the cardiovascular function and they
get more energy from it it helps them
lower blood pressure and i'm going to
tell you why because coenzyme q10
supports the blood vessel to the heart
as in the endothelial function it also
helps maintain the capacity of energy to
keep your energy in the heart at a
certain level so it doesn't dip down
because if there's a lowered level of
energy to the heart then your blood
pressure is going to start going higher
and higher and higher as a way to
compensate and increase more
pressure and volume to make up for the
loss of energy in other parts of the
heart so coenzyme q10 is intimately
involved in the contraction of the heart
muscle and so if you don't have enough
it could it's not going to contract as
much and then you can get a backup of
fluids edema and things like that and so
the body considers this coenzyme q10 as
a very important survival
helper molecule because if your heart
fails you're not going to actually
survive and coenzyme q10 reduces the
oxidative stress from the heart it helps
lower blood pressure it helps reduce the
side effects from statins which are
drugs that block the production of
cholesterol
so one of the problems with statin among
many others is that it has a side effect
of
toxicity to your muscles and that occurs
because it depletes coenzyme q10 and
that's interesting because it tells you
what coenzyme does it protects the heart
against things like muscle inflammation
muscle weakness
muscle damage and of course when you
have anything like that you're going to
have fatigue
so let's just picture yourself you ran
up a hill right well you're going to get
to a point where you can't keep going
right you're you're going to be
exhausted you're going to be hopping and
puffing and that's because the heart
cannot maintain that blood flow
and it's eventually going to stop you
you might just kind of be stooping over
hunched over because the heart is
working so hard it has to anchor itself
to the sternum and the back part and
it's going to pull you forward and so
coenzyme q10 is all about
increasing and optimizing the
full energy of the cardiovascular system
and so you can imagine the more coenzyme
q10 you have
the longer the heart is going to last
now the next question is what depletes
coenzyme q10
well
age the older you get the less you're
going to have okay number two
chronic illness
diabetes
inflammatory
illnesses next one is stress okay stress
will deplete it
and the next one i already talked about
statins and the last one is low vitamin
b6 okay so coenzyme q10 needs b6 to work
so now that you have the basics
what food can increase coenzyme q10 in
your body well the number one food is
you ready for this
beef heart now before you click off
there are some other sources if you
choose not to eat beef heart
you can also do beef liver that's
another one
unfortunately as much as i would eat
liver i don't like liver some people do
but you can get a good amount of
coenzyme q10 from organ meats and
especially the beef heart and even the
liver
but if you're like me and you want
another source
you can get it from leafy greens now
the
planet's main energy source is the sun
but we can't extract the energy directly
from the sun but plants can
through something called photosynthesis
right so the plant converts the sunlight
with co2 in the air
to this
chemical energy storage
called chlorophyll and chlorophyll is
green so anything green has a good
amount of chlorophyll in it now other
plants that are not green also have this
photosynthesis but they don't have as
much chlorophyll so the more foods that
you can eat that are green and i'm not
talking about pistachio ice cream or
lime green jello i'm talking about
salad
parsley especially or any of the leafy
green vegetables you are going to help
increase your co enzyme q10 not to
mention the other benefits of vegetables
potassium
magnesium
and of course the fiber in the plants
that feed the microbes that can also
indirectly give you energy now you can
also get chlorophyll in algae as in
blue-green algae or other types of algae
so that's another source now as far as
fish goes uh you'll get a little bit
more coenzyme q10 if you have the red
flesh fish like in yellowfin tuna that's
a good source so if you're getting older
and you're just feeling like your energy
is not high uh you could just need more
coenzyme q10 and why not just start
eating those foods that can help
beef up no pun intended your coenzyme
q10 and i think the best video for you
to watch next is the one on the
cardiovascular system check it out right
here